je sais qu'il ya mireille mathieu cayla
soir - mireille tu sais que c'est mon
ami et je travaille un pain secret tu
m'as dit il ya un petit peu rigide
j'aimerais par la mairie parce que tu la
mets énormément aimé et il a eu un petit
souci tandis que tu crois qu'elle est
fâché avec toi qui es six pattes ouais
non mireille on se connaît depuis très
longtemps gelé reçu toujours avec
bonheur elles se détestent et honneur
dans mes émissions d'état non il ya eu
une injustice totale à un moment elle a
pensé on m'a porter la responsabilité
sur un peu je voulais la recevoir la
radio il se trouve que les ondes de la
radio n'a pas voulu mais la personne qui
travaille avec elle dans sa maison a dit
voir a dit que c'était moi temps je
termine que c'est sérieux parce que je
l'adoré oui mais elle te déteste si tu
veux mais mirail on se voyait oui
aujourd'hui voilà tout ça c'était
vraiment sympathique ça me manque
voilà que j'aime pas lg mme mireille
j'aime ce qu'elle fait j'aime kerry un
peu j'adorais sa maman et oui j'étais
bouleversée c'était très bouleversée par
la mort de sa maman que j'aimais
profondément et quand je vois mireille
ça me touche énormément
je suis triste de 2,7 de ce petit front
entre nous à toi tu me fais de la peine
voilà la série alors la vérité c'est une
merde au pas on a été fâché c'est vrai
je le dit sheila vous c'est vrai que je
déballe granby tôt et quand on est ami
avec quelqu'un on est l'amitié c'est une
chose importante
on aura quand on fait de la peine ça
personnellement ça me ça ça m'a touché
et j'étais fâché qu'équivoques la mort
bernard je le disais je dis aujourd'hui
sur va mieux
vous nous sommes à un peu mieux
[Rires]
voilà derrière voilà pour l'instant pas
nécessaire en système ben ali c'est
exactement il a fait tellement mal
actuellement de la personne à qui la
fait plus de mal c'est le soleil et la
digue honnête elle a dit il est mort le
soleil a plus qu'on ne sait pas c'est à
quel point mireille et de roul bas je
sais bien sûr on l'a vu